من الاناقه قواعد واساسيات يفضل اتباعها
قواعد لا تختلف باختلاف الزمان او المكان
والخطا فيها
ممنوع في فقره فقرتنا الاسبوعيه مشاهدينا
محكمه الموضه نعالج فيها الازياء والصيحات
مع خبراء لكل ما هو مسموح وممنوع ايضا لكل
مناسبه لتنسيق افضل واطلالات اجمل
طيب بدنا نبلش الان مشاهدينا نرحب بضيفتنا
في الاستوديو خبيره المظهر لما علاء الدين
اهلا بك يا لمى
احنا طبعا هاي فقره جديده محكمه الموضه
بالضبط راح نشوف اربع
لبسات نعم يعني هذه نتبعها للرجال
واربعه لا انت طبعا
خلينا نبلش اذا هيك انا نعم ولا لا
خلينا خلينا
يلا اوكي هاي نعم ام لا هاي نعم
اكيد وليش بدي اقول نعم لانه
لابسه طويل للارض ولابسه معاه حذاء نفس
اللون فاعطى طول من تحت لفوق فوق زاد
الجذع السفلي اعطاه طول اكثر
والجاكيت مع الشنطه هيك اعطاها فكتير حبيت
حتى النظارات
ما ادري والله والله
صوره ثانيه اذا نعم هذا نعم هذه نعم ام لا
تطلع عليها بتقول نعم
بس انا وين كانت المشكله عندي بالحذاء
حذاء رياضي مش مبين حذاء رياض جيم يعني لو
نرفع بس
الحذاء الرياضي للجم يعني سنيكرز انعم او
تلبس بلارينا او كعب كان اعطى تواصل
بالاطلاله اوكي طيب
هذه نعم وبشده برضه مش مبينين اجريها
للاسف اول اشي الاوفر سايز شريط بس مش
لابساه فوق البنطلون حطاه جوا البنطلون
فبين حتى نصه الامامي ولكن مخليه النص
الخلفي برا برافو عليك راويه فعشان هيك
بين لي وين حصرها فقسم الجسم تلته ثلثين
فاعطى طول احنا مش شايفين شو لابسه بس هي
الحذاء اللي لابساه نود فما اعطي طول اللي
هو لونه نفس لون اللحمه بالضبط
اي قميص ولا ولا عم نحكي عن لون ازرق
حبيت جميل الرابع بعدها
هذه نو ولا لا
كل العرض حطاه بالجزء العلوي يعني الخطوط
العرضيه اعطت ضخامه غير انه طول الجاكيت
نازل لنصف طويل فقاسم الجسم نصين على كل
حال هذا بيطلع ماكسي علي يعني
بس بس كمان هي عملت خلط ما بين
المقلم بلونين مختلفين كمان مزعج شوي
وبعطيها ضخامه لجسمها لفوق ولو شفنا تحت
رجليها ببينوا سيقان كثير رفيعه يعني شيء
كثير رفيع حامل شيء كثير ضخم
الاول رجالي شو
رايك
اقدر البسه بس حلو
انا ما اقدر البسه بس حلو
هذا ايش لونه
مش مبين مش واضح كثير بس انا حبيت التناسق
حبيت الياقه الرفيعه ماشي مع يا
قه العم عياقه الجاكيت رفيعه
بشده
اللون هلا حتى في الصيف
اه لا لا لا برا لا نعم البنطلون من تحت
عشر سنين 15 سنه
بقول لك فيه لازم بريتسو البريكها من قدام
بس من ورا ولاء مش لازم يكون في تنميه
للبنطلون من ورا لازم ينزل دغري على الاجر
فهذا مبين انه لابس مقاس مش مقاسه اشي
اكبر منه الثالث
نعم حلو كثير حلو سعاده هذا بيطلع حلو
يعادل شوف ايش حابين طيب يلا
لا اله الا الله
حزام الساعه مع الحزام اللي لابسه مع
الحذاء اللي لابسه نفس اللون هذه من
اساسيات الاناقه يعني لما بتلبسي وبتلبقي
الالوان مع بعض غير انه لابس مقاسه الزلمه
مش اكثر مش اقل فلا حبيته بشده حلو طيب
اذا نعم وبشده اللي بعدها شو رايك عادل
اكيد لا لا بعنف مش عنق بيضاء مع
راسها
ربطه العنق تكون درجه اغمق درجه من القميص
لازم اغمق ولازم مش نفس النقشه عشان تبين
الربطه فهاي طبعا نفس اللون فلا بشده حتى
القميص غريب شوي طالع كانه نص تيشرت نص
قميص هلا انا حبيت اركز اكثر على لون
الربطه عشان يعرف لازم درجه اغمق او
درجتين من القميص ونناقشه تكون مختلفه هو
ممكن مع بيج بس انه ايضا ما معطي شيء
مميز اي مش مبين اذا لا
خلصنا احنا اعتقد
خليني اسهل بين اليوم بالنسبه للرجال
الاوفر سايز دايما موجود
كمان في صوره ثانيه ما ادري طيب اذا في
صوره ثانيه اعطونا اياها لا احنا رجعنا
خليني اسال بالنسبه للرجال الاوفر سايز او
المقاسات الكبيره هل بالصيف مستمره معانا
الالوان يعني انت فاجئتيني باللون النبيذي
احنا نقول هذا صيفي مو شتوي
الموضه البني يعني تخيل بالصيف نازل موضه
ونازل لون مثلا اخضر على اصفر اخضر مصفر
نازل موضه للرجال عم باهي الالوان نازله
موضه هلا للنساء طب النساء شو في
كل شيء
من حقنا شو هيك خطوط بس هيك عامه وعريضه
لشو هي الموضه سواء من ناحيه بالنسبه
للسيدات بهذا الصيف الوانه قصت
الالوان هذا الاخضر الليموني نازل للبني
البنفسجي الفاتح
الموف الموف هلا نازل
الالوان الترابيه يعني ايضا مستمره
الالوان الترابيه عادل لازم تكون اساسي
بخزانتك اصلا بكل دولاب حدا وتكون 80%
عشان تقدر تشيل وتبدل وتحط براحتك لانه
تلبق على كل الالوان الثانيه فالالوان
الترابيه او النيوترا اللي بنقول عنها
اساسيه
[موسيقى]
الهديه اللي راح تجيبي لي اياها كل
الالوان وانا كمان
المره الجايه
لك الدين خبيره المضحك في الاستوديو
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات